hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and in this video
i'm going to be answering all of your
niggling property investment questions
there's a lot of changes going on at the
moment in legislation and within the
property market generally for buy to let
landlords but also for property
entrepreneurs so any questions that
you've got about some of the new changes
that are happening any challenges
problems do me a massive favor and
comment your questions below and what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna answer your
questions and that not only is going to
help you but it's also going to help
everybody that watches my channel and
all of my subscribers so comment your
questions your challenges below and i'll
do my best to answer also if you haven't
already please do hit the like button
and make sure you subscribe channel it's
amazing how many people watch my channel
but aren't even subscribed so they don't
get notified of the latest videos so
subscribe to the channel and also turn
the notification bell on that would help
me out massively and don't forget to
start commenting your questions below
last week we had some really interesting
questions and comments um a guy called
andrew crampton had a question about epc
which i'm going to read in a minute i
have got a lot to say about epc and if
any of these questions and as i'm
answering if you get an offshoot of a
question just comment it below in the
comment box so andrew said it'd be good
to get your thoughts on the minimum epc
increase to a c by 2025
that's proposed by the government
okay so
what that means is epc stands for energy
performance certificate so every house
every residential house will have an epc
certificate and the certificate could be
anywhere from an a up to an e
okay a means that the energy performance
of the house is really really efficient
it's really really good not many houses
are a's not even many houses are b's
most properties tend to be c's or d's if
it's any higher than an e if it's an f
or a g
then you cannot rent the house out um
because it means that it's not insulated
profit properly
the energy performance is so bad that
they say you can't rent a property out
that's anything higher than an e
however what the government are
introducing is they're saying that
they're going to increase the standard
of epc
ratings from an e to a c
what do i think about that well for a
start it's going to affect a lot of
landlords because i think about a third
of landlords think that they're going to
be affected by this because a lot of
property especially older style
properties like victorian houses a lot
of them are d's
some of them are even ease
so the fact they're saying it has to be
a minimum of a c
is going to mean that
a lot of landlords are going to have to
spend some money and it's going to be
that it could be thousands of pounds to
bring down the rating to make it run
more effectively they might have to
maybe get solar panels or
i mean to be fair
listen you can moan about these things
and you can say isn't it terrible oh
some of my properties won't comply i'm
have to spend money
and i understand why landlords are upset
but there are some things that you just
can't control i'm not going to start a
petition and say oh it's terrible
because actually it's not a bad thing
that houses are more efficient so
i'm not going to stand here and start a
petition and say the government
shouldn't change the the standard uh
neither am i going to moan and say oh
i'm sure some of my properties
many of them are d's and i'll have to
try and
bring it make it better and maybe spend
money to a c but at the same time um
our rents are going up at the moment
interest rates are very very low and
there's some mortgage lenders like the
mortgage works who are saying that
they're gonna they're gonna um
reward people for bringing their energy
performance certificates better they're
actually offering
1.5
interest payments which is just
ridiculously low so
i think rather than moaning about i've
got to spend three grand five grand
whatever i would probably say there are
some landlords that are going to sell up
which again creates opportunity
um
there's opportunity and disappointment
it's a combination but you're always
better off seeing the opportunity it's
good to have properties that have got a
good energy performance certificate it's
good for you it's good for the tenants
it's good for the environment um so
overall am i worried
not too worried especially as we've been
given four years notice
they're also the government are offering
grants
so i've done a video about this before
they're offering to pay towards any
property including landlords that are
looking to make their properties greener
so
overall i'm reasonably positive about it
even though it will be a little bit of
an inconvenience for sure so that's my
thoughts i hope that helps andrew let me
know what you think let me know
generally what do you think do you think
it's a good thing a bad thing what do
you think of my opinion comment below
i'd love to hear your thoughts and
opinions
michael day says
need your advice i've got a new job in
bristol and i'm buying a house on a
residential mortgage
and let out the spare is letting out the
spare room a good idea as i already have
a house down in dorset okay so if you're
buying a house in bristol to live in
and you've already got a property indoor
set
is it a good idea sure
if you can buy a house and then you can
put a lodger in and that lodge i mean
for a start you're gonna get bedroom
relief tax so you're not gonna have to
pay any tax for the first seven and a
half thousand pounds a year which will
probably be the entire amount of rent
from the lodge so it's tax-free income
secondly if you've got permission to do
it
that money is probably going to pay for
your mortgage payments so i think it's a
really good setup
may be worth considering renting if
you're just going to be moving to
bristol short term because if you've
already got a house and door set if you
want to move back to dorset you might
end up with this house that you don't
want which which is never a good idea
because you've got to pay stamp duty tax
if you end up selling it you're going to
get hit with more taxes legal fees um
but yeah sure sounds like a good idea
michael all the best with the move to
bristol
stan ken stan kim says
how do i do proper due diligence on a
deal eg a brr deal
what factors metrics should i work out
so a brr deal which stands for a buy
refurbished refinance rent deal which is
very standard for property investors the
due diligence you're going to need to do
number one is you're going to need to
know
um what the refurb is going to be so
you're going to need a survey on the
property you're going to need to make
sure that you know exactly how much it's
going to cost to refurb the property
you're also going to need to speak to
estate agents and look on land registry
look on right move at sold prices in the
area and you're going to need to know
how much your property is going to be
worth once you've done it up
and and there's also just the usual
thing so for instance um once you've
refinanced it what's the new mortgage
payment going to be
is that going to be able to be covered
by the rent
what's your profit going to be what's
your ultimate return on investment going
to be so these are the kind of questions
that you really need to look at when
buying a property i hope that helps
all right next a deal says
i need to ask you i bought a two-bed
terraced house and i want to change two
bed to three bed with a stood wall
and create a window for that room do i
need planning permission for that or can
i do it straight away
thanks
dude it really depends it does depend if
if you were just literally putting a
stud wall when creating a second room
then you wouldn't need planning
permission for that but if you're going
to actually create a window
you may need planning permission i think
it would depend on for a start does the
window is this window going to be
overlooking is it going to be affecting
people's privacy i definitely wouldn't
just go and do it straight away without
speaking because also if you're going to
be building a window in place um i would
speak to building control i would speak
to the council um it it depends whether
you need planning permission you may not
um i'd have to i'd have to see it maybe
i definitely would speak though to a
planning consultant before you just
start doing the work because if you
carry out work and you hope that you
don't need planning and then it turns
out that you did need planning but you
didn't get planning
they can
make you
undo all of the work which is just such
a demoralizing thing to have to do so
don't just do it but i'm sure you'll be
able to get permissions i'm sure it'd be
absolutely fine and i hope that it adds
a lot of value to your house
okay matt bex
how you doing matt i hope you are well
matt says what are the average interest
rates and fees with bridging loans if a
brr project is six months what are the
average costs
so bridging loans
really vary typically you're probably
going to be talking about 12
per annum so if it's just for six months
you're probably going to pay about six
percent on that there may be an in an
in-and-out fee an exit fee um so they
sometimes might charge you one percent
um a one percent exit fee so
you're probably talking about six eight
percent of the money that you're
borrowing if you're only for six months
but of course it really depends on you
it depends on the deal it depends on the
lender but anywhere between
10 and 15
would be about normal per annum for a
bridging loan
all right last question i hope you're
enjoying this by the way do hit the like
button also if you've got questions i'd
love to answer your property investment
questions as well so don't forget to
comment anything at all comment below
and i'll be answering your questions
next week but we've got ayub musa that
says how do i get a corporate let
contract or what is the best way to sort
the contract out a company let just
means an ast it can be an ast contract
it's a company
letting
a house or a property so it's an
agreement a contract but rather than the
house being led to an individual it's
the house being led to a company so most
letting agents will actually have
corporate let's
in in their letting agencies they'll if
oh you're a company no problem and
they'll give you a company let contracts
however if you're looking to do things
like rent to rent
or rent to serviced accommodation then
you want that company let to have some
clauses in there for example you want
break clauses in there so it might be
worth speaking to a solicitor to draw up
the contract and making sure that
depending on what the purpose of the
company that is you're covered at all
angles also it will protect the set of
the the owner as well um
if you're doing if you're one of my
students on i've read to rent training
then we we can provide uh company that's
that you can tweak
but it really depends on what the
purpose is if it's just if it's just a
case of like this house that i'm in at
the moment
this house that i'm in at the moment is
rented by my company and i live in here
and it's a very straightforward company
left because i'm not subrenting anything
out nothing like that it's just my
company's renting the property that's
really straightforward but if you're
gonna be doing rent-to-rent make sure
that you do get a proper contract which
you get solicited to draw up or if
you're one of my students then that's
something that we can provide as well i
hope you guys found this video useful
please don't forget to hit the like
button if you want to see more videos
like this there's an entire playlist up
here if you want to join me at the
property investors crash course i'll
leave a link in the description and i
wish you all the best in your property
investment journey thanks